es ist der Abschluss eines Events das
für die Menschen hier nicht weniger als
ein Wendepunkt im Leben sein soll nach
diesen zwei Tagen so das Versprechen
wird sich alles
[Musik]
verändern ihre Hoffnungen setzen sie in
jürgen Höller Deutschlands bekanntestem
motivationss und
Erfolgscoach ich möchte mir Devin ich
habe kann ich auch gerne in Zahlen sagen
etwas über 70 000 bereits in mich
investiert nie aufzugeben finde ich mega
ich spiele mit dem Gedanken ein
Folgeseminar zu buchen auf jeden Fall so
viel Geld haben dass ich selber sag okay
ich kann meiner Mama ein Haus kaufen
überall in Deutschland suchen Menschen
Coachs auf die Branche boomt und wird
gefahren hier in der München
Olympiahalle finden zwei Tage lang die
sogenannten Power dayss von Jürgen
Höller statt
ich will herusfinden wer hierhert warum
die Menschen hierherkmen und ich bin
sehr gespannt was uns
erwartet Motivation als Geschäftsidee
der Trend kam in den 90er Jahren nach
Deutschland diesmal sind 10000
Teilnehmerinnen und Teilnehmer gekommen
die Versprechungen sind
groß mehr Energie höhere Umsätze ein
unbeschwertes Leben es ist ein Geschäft
mit der Hoffnung mich interessiert nicht
wie es dir heute geht denn das ist eine
Zwischenbilanz was mich interessiert ist
wie es dir morgen geht was mich
interessiert ist die Frage was du morgen
aus deinem Potenzial gemacht h viele
Menschen hier sind an einem beruflichen
oder privaten Wendepunkt sie wollen ihr
Leben
umkrempeln wir sehen doch nur die großen
wenn sie groß sind wir sehen den
Fußballspieler wir sehen den influenzer
wir sehen den Schauspieler wir sehen den
Reden auf der Bühne aber wir haben nicht
gesehen wie sie groß wurden und was sie
alles getan haben dafür Höller
inspiriert die Leute auch wegen seiner
Geschichte jürgen Höller Deutschlands
Motivationstrainer Nummer 1 der
Hauptvorwurf Insolvenzverschleppung und
Untreue nach kurzem Prozess das Urteil 3
Jahre ohne Bewehrung Höller der zuvor
ein umfassendes Geständnis abgelegt
hatte hat während der Untersuchungshaft
bereits ein neues Buch geschrieben der
und immer wieder
aufstehen die Zeit im Gefängnis ist ein
biograischer Tiefpunkt den Höller heute
geschickt für sich
n Stunden später war ich auf 8 quadr
alleine für dann eineinhalb
Jahre ich habe alle emotionalen Phasen
erlebt die man in einer großen
[Musik]
lebensk
Erfolgsgeschichte und einmal schaffst du
es
noch einmal schaffst du noch und in dem
Moment bin ich aufgestanden und habe
geschrien steh jetzt auf
Jürgen sehr sehr interessant zu fallen
tief zu fallen und wieder aufzustellen
nie aufzugeben finde ich mega und das
ist eigentlich auch so das was ich lebe
also man man sollte einfach niemals
aufgeben es gibt kein das ist aufgeben
ist keine Option Stefanie erzählt mir
dass sie seit kurzem selbst als Coach
tätig ist ich versuch gerade mein
Business aufzubauen ich bin da auch noch
so ein bisschen in den Kind steck noch
in den Kinderschuhen
und na ja also da gehört einfach
wahnsinnig viel Mut zu die hat er
bewiesen das finde ich klasse das
Vorbild selbst übt sich in
demonstrativer
bescheidenheitchsteners ich kann den
Leuten nur aufzeigen wie sie die Wege
gehen die müssen stehen sie müssen ins
Handeln kommen niemand kann jemanden
erfolgreich machen niemand kann den
anderen glücklicher machen niemand kann
anderen motivieren ich kann nur das
Wissen geben wir auf einem Buffet und
dann müssen sie zugreifen auf diesen
Buffet so sieht er sich als Wegbereiter
zu mehr Erfolg aber jeder muss selbst
sehen wie er vorankommt ich habe kann
ich auch gerne Zahlen sagen etwas über
70 000 bereit mich investiert in
Marketing Vertrieb
Persönlichkeitsentwicklung ich habe
wenig Freizeit gehabt die let Jahre ich
habe viel gearbeitet ich habe auf viele
Dinge verzichtet und ich habe halt immer
überlegt okay wie kann ich halt noch
mehr Umsatz machen Selbstoptimierung als
Synonym für ein geglücktes leben die
Arbeit an sich selbst macht viele hier
glücklich eine Art
Schicksalsgemeinschaft die Power und
vergleichbare Veranstaltungen sind für
die teilnehmenden so eine Art
selbstvertrauensbooster und auf solchen
Massen kommen natürlich gleichgesinte
zusammen welche Rolle also spielt das
große Kollektiv und mit welchen Methoden
arbeiten die Coachs um die Massen hinter
sich zu bringen ich treffe Dieter frei
Professor für Sozialpsychologie an der
Ludwig Maximilians Universität
München also ist ganz wichtig diese
Gemeinschaft dass sie sehen ich bin ja
gar nicht alleine und wenn so viele
andere auch da sind dann muss ja was
wahres dran sein und dann kann ich nicht
der Einzige sein der davon nicht
profitiert also ganz witig diese Menge
ich rede fast von Massen suugestion ein
massenelektrizismus also massenuphorie
all das gibt es nicht nur bei Höller die
coachingbranche boomt es geht um
Geld nicht um dich es geht um deine
zukünftigen Kunden und darum du mit
deiner Geschichte
andererees um neue Identität und dann
stell vor wie sich deintig ich mit dir
auf die Couch
setzt und dein zukünftiges Ich ihre oder
seine Hand auf dein Herz legt und um
komplexe
Psychologie macht sein Leben heute noch
zur Hölle merkt das gerade merkt das
jeder hier im Raum denn das bist auch du
und weißt du was das gute ist all das
was damals passiert ist ist überhaupt
nicht mehr
wahr du bist nicht mehr dieser sie J
junge die inszenierte Heilung eines
Kindheitstrauma auf offener Bühne
untermalt mit
[Musik]
Musik ein Moment des Glücks doch
wissenschaftlich fundiert sind die
Methoden
nicht
bist weil der Begriff Coach nicht
geschütztn jeder so nennen bei der
Recherche fällt mir auf konkrete Zahlen
zur Branche sind schwer zu bekommen es
gibt wohl zwischen 30 und 40.000 Coachs
in Deutschland Jahresumsatz mehr als
eine halbe Milliarde Euro oft werden die
Menschen über Events oder online
sememinare geloggt und sollen dann teure
Aufbaukurse buchen Informationsstellen
die eigentlich Aussteiger aus Sekten
beraten sehen eine immer höhere Zahl von
Betroffenen die sich im Netz teurer
coachingseminare verliert Höller hat
Konkurrenz bekommen also ich
2004 mit meinem Comeback gestartet bin
wird es be 20 Jahre her da gab es
ungefähr 30.000
Weiterbildner jetzt kommen jedes Jahr
30.000 neue auf dem Markt also Berater
Trainer Speaker Coaches das heißt so
viel wie damals insgesamt tätig waren
kommen jetzt in einem Jahr neu in den
Markt wenn so viele auf dem Markt
drängen die angeblich Experten sind soll
man schon dahinter schauen wer ist
wirklich ein Experte wer behauptet nur
doch auch bei Höller sollen die Leute
folgeseminare abschließen könnt ja nicht
mehr entschließen das lifing Seminar zu
buchen weil es kostet Geld und vier Tage
der Zeit ja wenn wenn du da dich schon
nicht entscheiden kannst wenn du da
schon nicht mehr mal ein bisschen Geld
in die Hand nimmst um in dich zu
investieren ja wie willst du den dann
vom Universum erwarten dass deine Träume
die größer sind dein Potenzial das
vielleicht noch gewaltig du weißt ja
nicht was noch in dir steckt dass du das
dann vom Universum geliefert bekommst
die Rhetorik wirkt jeder fünte bis drte
der Teilnehmer schließt ein weiteres
Seminar
ab ich möchte mit dem lüfingeminar
beginnen weil ich gesehen habe dass man
hier viel mental mitnehmen kann fürs
mindset die Seminare sind um ein Drittel
reduziert auf ca 2000 € nur ein erster
Schritt zu einem aberwitzigen Ziel ich
möchte Milliardär werden Milliardär
Milliardär du hast mich richtig
verstanden ja aber mir geht's gar nicht
direkt ums Geld s ich möchte das sind
zwei zi die miteinander gehen ich möchte
ein Imperium
aufbauen die Leute glauben wenn ich das
jetzt auch noch mache dann hilft es und
da die Sehnsucht größer ist als der
Realismus
machen sie das Menschen sind keine
rationalen Wesen sondern
rationalisierende Wesen wenn ich jetzt
700 € und noch mal 3000 drauf bezahle
dann habe ich ganz schön viel
Rechtfertigungsdruck ich kann ja
schlecht draußen sag ich war so
bescheuert und habe das gemacht sondern
ich muss das rechtf sein das war
super wenn die Emotion über die Vernunft
siegt und so hoffen viele hier dass das
Geld nicht verschwendet ist und doch
noch irgendwie ein Wunder
[Musik]
geschieht
ه